after 130 years a famous statue of
robert e lee has fallen in richmond
virginia the great general one of the
most important figures not only in the
civil war but also in bringing the
country back together after the union
army won
will be hidden away in storage for the
foreseeable future and while the libs
celebrate the demise of general lee we
are left to ask ourselves a simple
question
is america a better place now that the
statue has been torn down
has any american's life improved
is it possible even that america is
actually a worse place because of this
desecration
is it possible that i don't know maybe
there's a reason that we might all be
missing right now as to why the statue
was put up in the first place no it
couldn't be
just like the taliban the libs will tear
down the historical monument and get
ready to destroy the next one i'm
michael knowles that's the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comedy yesterday is from the scoundrels
cantina who says a heartbeat on earth is
not life but bacteria on mars is
so say the democrats that's true they do
say that
because they are doing anything they can
to deny that a life is a life so now
they're denying that a heartbeat does a
heartbeat
they will go to any length to
avoid seeing what is plainly in front of
them now if you don't want other people
to see what you are up to on the
internet i would strongly recommend you
check out expressvpn the asymmetries of
power between big tech and us
are historic okay this sort of thing has
never been seen before in history it's
so much worse than even you think it is
to fight back against big tech's control
of the internet i use expressvpn when
you use expressvpn on your computer or
on your phone you anonymize much of your
online presence by hiding your ip
address that makes your activity much
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals takes
just one click to protect all of your
devices that's why expressvpn is rated
number one by cnet
i do not go online anymore without
expressvpn it's so easy to use i don't
really need to think about it and it
just prevents people from snooping on
you
so let's stop allowing big tech
companies to revoke our rights to free
speech why not revoke their right to
your data instead secure your internet
with vpn i trust for online protection
expressvpn.com
michael exp or essvpn.com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l to get three extra months
for free with my exclusive web link
that's expressvpn.com
michael right now to learn more
president trump is being
excoriated for his statement on the
removal of the robert e lee statue
oh robert the historians are making fun
of him
the everyone's calling him a racist
he's being called an idiot well here's
what he said just watched as a massive
crane took down the magnificent and very
famous statue of robert e lee on his
horse in richmond it has long been
recognized as a beautiful piece of
bronze sculpture to add insult to injury
those who support this taking now plan
to cut it into three pieces and throw
this work of art into storage prior to
its complete desecration
robert e lay is considered by many
generals to be the greatest strategist
of all president lincoln wanted him to
command the north in which case the war
would have been over in one day
i love his just look he's a great
general okay folks not like those other
crappy generals uh robert e lee instead
chose the other side because of his
great love of virginia and except for
gettysburg would have won the war he
should be remembered as perhaps the
greatest unifying force after the war
was over ardent in his resolve to bring
the north and south together through
many means of reconciliation and
imploring his soldiers to do their duty
in becoming good citizens of this
country this is a very important point
and trump is absolutely 100 correct here
okay
and of course he won't get credit for
saying it but it's very important just
like chesterton's fence
people should be very careful about
tearing down these civil war monuments
chesterton's fence this idea i'm
oversimplifying a little bit but the
idea that when a reformer walks into the
middle of a field and sees a fence there
and he has no reason
no understanding as to why the fence
might be there and he says we're going
to tear it down the wise thing to do is
to say no no no you can't tear it down
first you have to understand why it was
put up in the first place then and only
then
should you consider whether or not you
want to tear it down
the same goes for these civil war
monuments why are these being put up in
the first place is it just because
robert e lee is
this great wonderful american well in
many ways he was a wonderful american he
was a very good general
lincoln did want him to fight for the
north and but he didn't because he had
his love of virginia but
that last point there i think might be
the most important he was
among the most important figures after
the war to bring the north and south
back together and reform america it was
very important for that and when
president lincoln called for malice
toward none and charity for all this is
what he's talking about
the south
much to the left's consternation is part
of america i live in the south now i'm a
good old southern boy
you you this is part of the country the
left wishes that we're not part of the
country but it is so either you're going
to live together you're going to love
one another you're going to recognize
that this is a fallen world and
there are going to be bad things that
happen in this world but we're just
going to move on together and try to
pursue the good and try to avoid evil or
you can tear down everything and tear
down your fellow americans
and preen and and stand on the shoulders
of giants and pretend that you're flying
and that that's what's going on here
that's and it's not gonna end with
robert e lee as trump called it four
years ago he said they're not just going
after robert e lee they're going to tear
down jefferson and washington and
everyone laughed at him and then two
seconds later they're tearing down
jefferson and washington this is taliban
style stuff
we we whine and cry and render garments
because the taliban blow up buddha
statues in afghanistan they're doing the
same thing here not the taliban the
american left they're tearing down our
statues they're tearing down our
monuments they're tearing down our
history that's what's happening
speaking of the taliban
you know
there's been a lot of talk because of
this abortion law in texas about the
texas taliban it's this is terrible to
women there it's just what's the
difference between texas and afghanistan
the better comparison is to the libs
okay
not just because the libs are tearing
down all our statues and burning down
the country and committing
vigilante terrorist violence
but
also because
they are very difficult to understand
they're incoherent
donald trump was on greg gutfeld's show
and he was describing his interactions
with the taliban
because it's very difficult
uh to deal with these people because
they're they're pretty hard to
understand okay so i told you about
abdul so he's tough and when i first
spoke to him by phone
i said
nice to speak to you by phone abdul and
he goes
you know they're ferocious people right
you know like you go to broadway shows
they fight they like to fight they've
been fighting for about a thousand years
how long broadway show me the lie
show me the lie there was a journalist
aaron rupar at vox.com and he was very
upset about this and he tweeted out
trump suggests taliban leaders
communicate in primitive grunts and
groans
i think instead of the word suggests he
meant to say observes this plain fact
that's before all of our eyes
this is how to think about the taliban
trump has got it right
okay because i've seen
some wild reactions here some people on
the right because of how
awful our culture has gotten some people
on the right on the right have said oh
you know the taliban
they're painting over the george floyd
mural that's not so bad i mean they get
they get a few things right even a stop
clock right
the the libs are very conflicted
about their feelings toward the taliban
because they hate america so they love
america's enemies but the taliban are
this
regressive
traditionalist islamic culture so they
don't know if they can quite like that
what what trump understands that the
libs don't
is
that different
peoples are different
different cultures are different with
what the libs believe is that the
taliban are basically just sort of
misunderstood
or they just they just don't have enough
iphones or you know which they actually
do have iphones and they're posting
memes to twitter
they just don't have enough jobs they
don't have enough
mcdonald's if they had more mcdonald's
then they would they would act just like
us
i mean barack obama said this he said
the reason that there are problems in
the middle east is they don't have
enough money and gadgets and gizmos and
you know modern western
dress and movies that's not it it's not
i i know it's difficult for western libs
to understand this right now because
they don't believe in anything they all
they're after is just making money and
pleasuring themselves but people
actually do have beliefs
and they act on those beliefs and we in
the west used to have that too
and we first really went up against the
east and then the muslims when the
muslims tried to invade europe and we
repelled them this is going back to 732
that the battle of poitiers also called
the battle of tours and then
a few centuries later you see this in
the crusades a clash of two different
cultures both of whom really believe in
something both of whom really are
willing to die for for something for a
belief for their understanding of god
and now there's a lot of revisionist
history that's trying to
figure out any sort of reason that the
crusaders might have gone to war
whether it was for money whether it was
for land other than the one that's
obvious that they actually believed in
something
but we can't understand that in the west
anymore
we can't understand that cultural
difference trump does he says yeah i
talked to these guys it was like
he's he's making fun of them he's
describing them as a sort of savage type
type of person who is not civilized in
the way that the west is civilized he's
right he's right as he often is he's
right though there's not a ton of
civility going on here in the west these
days either as you may have noticed
larry elder is running for governor of
california in the recall election so
he's walking through some neighborhood
in california
and a
lady in a gorilla mask throws an egg at
him
you see larry walking down
white lady in a gorilla mask
throws an egg at him she's on a bike
don't touch her
don't touch him then she punches one of
larry's
body
then another kooky guy and then they're
throwing more stuff
so then they put they put larry in the
car they drive away
this is like a campaign commercial for
larry elder here here's california under
new some elect literally anybody else
when you just want to tune out some of
the craziness in the world what i would
strongly recommend you should check out
raycons how are you listening to me
right now
are you listening to me through some
speakers are you listening to me through
some of those buggy looking
headsets that kind of have the stem
sticking out and they don't you know
they don't work that well well
please correct your behavior
and check out raycons raycons
sound beautiful better than the other
stuff on the market they look a lot
better than the other stuff on the
market they've got a bunch of gel tips
for your comfort they come in a bunch of
stylish color ways they've got a 32-hour
battery life so you can listen to what
you want when you want to for a really
really long time and
cherry on top they start at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you cannot lose give them a
try right now seriously you will see
what i mean create your own soundtrack
with raycon right now my listeners can
get 15 off their raycon order at raycon
dot com slash knowles go get my absolute
favorite earbuds i love them by
raycon.com slash knowles to say 15 on
raycons by raycon.com
knowles
a white lib she seemed white i don't
know if she's white or hispanic or so
she seemed kind of fairer skinned
a lib in a gorilla mask just threw some
an egg at larry elder larry elder you
see
is the black face of white supremacy
that's
that's the line from the la times and uh
it you know he's not just a sort of
amiable libertarian black guy from south
central no he's the far right radical
white supremacist black guy and that's
why political violence is justified to
stop him that's what that's what the
left is implying and that's what they're
perpetrating against him right now
i'm not even going to say it you know
you know what every
reaction to this is well
well if the rules were reversed if the
situation were reversed yeah we all know
that we know the problem here is
that
the hypothetical doesn't do us any good
we know that there are different
standards here
i mean they're willing to call
larry elder a white supremacist the the
positive takeaway from this should be
when they call you a racist just who
cares who cares it doesn't mean anything
don't let it get to you man wear it as a
badge of honor to be called a racist by
some dishonest idiot lib where it's a it
means you've won the argument
means they fear you and they fear larry
elder
do you know other white supremacists i
just found out about is shapiro
ben is it white soprano i didn't know
that
last i checked the white supremacists no
not so hot on the chosen people
uh but there was a
a meme that was going around listing ben
as a white supremacist i said okay this
has got to be from some far left radical
group probably some group that doesn't
have any power right it's the center for
progress and advancement and antifa and
oh no it's from google
it's from google the most powerful
company on earth
google is holding a quote-unquote
anti-racist training for its employees
and it claims that there's a direct link
between ben shapiro
and mass murder
there's a graphic it's called the white
supremacy pyramid
it shows that
at the bottom of the pyramid this is the
sort of broadest level of white
supremacy is the phrase all lives matter
that's white supremacy so if you say
that white people shouldn't just be
summarily executed you're a white
supremacist
that so all lives matter
you're beginning then you move up to ben
ben is right above that that's on
minimization that's so that's the white
supremacy thing and some other guys next
to him whom i don't know then
two spots up you see trump
and then
i don't know some other people of
violence and then mass murder so shapiro
i i do look i'm not saying that ben is
totally innocent okay he does have
murder in his heart every time he looks
at me but otherwise i don't think he's a
very violent guy he's a sort of
mild-mannered
orthodox jew generally not welcomed by
the skinheads this is what we're up
against and we can we're laughing about
it it's funny
google
has
more power
than
just about any institution in the
country i would say the government sort
of has more power but google and the
government are not so easily separated
google and the government own multiple
properties together
google in many ways is part of the
government they're the enforcement arm
they're a proxy for the government to do
the government's dirty work very often
the the
disparities of power
are unprecedented right now google's
power compared to the power of the
american people
is is so radically greater
i don't think there's any comparison in
history they control our speech they
control our behavior in some ways they
know every single thing about us they
know more about us than we know about
ourselves
and they run the government
and they're calling some people mass
murderers so what happens what happens
if you are successfully labeled a white
supremacist a mass murderer a genocidal
maniac
you can very easily be censored
ostracized or have violence committed
against you
that's the point
it's it would be
defensive
the implication here from the google
slide is that if you
kill ben shapiro it's self-defense
because ben shapiro's leading to mass
murder
it only followed they won't come out and
say it outright but that's
the inevitable implication
and ben is a stand-in for you and me ben
he's pretty mainstream right
there are people who are to the right of
ben shapiro many of them
all of those people
absolutely not permitted
in the public discourse
now there is a little you're getting a
little bit of pushback the the left is
getting so aggressive that even people
who are generally liberal
some of them are beginning to feel a
little uncomfortable i'm thinking in
particular of the
cardinal of the archdiocese of
washington so this is joe biden's
catholic
cardinal the guy who is sort of
responsible for
washington dc cardinal gregory
cardinal gregory is
pretty liberal
as far as
catholic prelates go
cardinal gregory famously infamously
attacked donald trump while he was
president
for
going to visit a catholic shrine
he was offended that
donald trump went to visit the shrine of
saint john paul ii
that's that's how
liberal and left this cardinal is and
yet even this cardinal
has finally
broken his silence on joe biden's
formal heresy on abortion
last week president biden said he did
not agree that life begins at conception
were you surprised to hear that and can
you clarify the church's teaching
on when life begins
the catholic church teaches and has
taught
that life human life
begins at conception
so the president
is not demonstrating catholic teaching
okay
now
among the theologians
there's all kinds of
medical issues
about when does conception take place
when is it that implantation
is it
at some point
when the sperm and the ovum come
together and and and create
a new
uh
reality uh and and theologians have
debated that and continue to debate that
oh my goodness gracious
as respectfully as i possibly can i've
got to point out here
cardinal gregory is doing everything he
can everything he possibly can to defend
joe biden's indefensible heresy
so he's saying well
joe biden is not
demonstrating catholic
teaching
you mean he's a heretic you mean he's
he's
renouncing his faith he's not practicing
his religion well yes though there is
debate over when conception takes place
even if that were the case
that's not what's at issue here
we're talking about six-week abortion
laws
we're talking about heartbeat bills
regardless of whether you want to
parse the nuances of whether conception
is when
the the new baby implants which it's not
or it when the sperm and the ovum come
together to create a new reality also
known as a human life
which it is
regardless of that fine you have that
debate that's fine by me
that's completely irrelevant
no one no one is suggesting right now
that
we should
permit abortion before implantation
but but not after implantation so you
after the after the sperm and the egg
come together you can no none of that is
is on the table we're talking about a
heartbeat
and what joe biden is saying is
explicitly he said i do not believe that
life begins at the moment of conception
so regardless of where you say the
moment of conception is it doesn't
matter biden is
regardless engaging in formal heresy but
he doesn't want to do it the new reality
it's a euphemism to me it's a human
being it's a human being and even i
don't mean to go after cardinal gregory
too much here i'm glad that he is
articulating the church's plain teaching
on this to our heretic president the
second man who
at least pretends to be a catholic even
though he's not a practicing catholic
but i wish he were clearer about it i
wish he weren't even giving joe biden
that much wiggle room it's he doesn't
deserve that much wiggle room it's not
true it's not just
and if the church cannot speak out
clearly
on life it can't speak out on anything
at all that's why cardinal gregory is
saying yes biden is not
not going along with catholic teaching
here
right so let's try to change that let's
let's not beat around the bush okay now
among all of these various debates does
it begin at the fertilization the
implantation is where does it begin all
of the people who are debating this
are still less confused
than alexandria ocasio-cortez alexandria
ocasio-cortez is demonstrating the
most delightful tension of this abortion
debate
namely
the left pretends that men can get
pregnant
but the left also demagogues abortion as
a women's issue and pro-life as an
example of the patriarchy which can
exist because men and women are no
longer to be distinguished except when
it's convenient for the left are you
confused me too
now if you want to be able to sleep a
little bit better
be able to think a little more clearly
wrap your head around these things with
a good night's sleep i strongly
recommend you check out bio optimizers i
want you to enter into my bed okay come
into my bedroom
because i sleep like a baby you
you might not sleep like a bit you might
be having trouble falling asleep and
staying asleep well one of the best
things you can possibly do to start
getting enough sleep
is to start getting enough magnesium
unfortunately most magnesium supplements
use only the two cheapest synthetic
forms since they're not full spectrum
they will not fix your magnesium
deficiency or help you sleep better
which is why i recommend magnesium
breakthrough by by optimizers simply
take two capsules before you go to bed
you will be amazed at how much better
you sleep and how much more rested you
feel when you wake up it is really
really important to get enough sleep at
night for an exclusive offer
right now just for my listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com knowles and use code
knolls10 to save 10 when you try
magnesium breakthrough and one more
thing
for a limited time buy optimizers is
also giving away free bottles of their
best selling products
p30m and massimes with select purchases
so go to magbreakthrough.com
knowles right now get your exclusive 10
discount plus a chance to get more than
50 worth of supplements for free go
check out bio optimizers today also this
october not only will backstage be live
and on stage at the famous ryman
auditorium right here in nashville
we're also giving one lucky member a
chance to win two vip tickets to get
front row seats and not just that but
the winner will receive a 1500 gift card
to cover travel expenses a meet and
greet with the backstage hosts including
yours truly and more
tickets for the ryman show sold out
already so this is your one chance to
get in on the action to enter go to
dailywire.com slash subscribe and join
one of our membership plans with the
code backstage for 25 off your
membership if you're already a member
you'll be automatically entered so get
ready because you might just be on your
way to nashville to meet and watch me
ben jeremy matt drew candice next month
you can also order right now it is
available in shipping the new 70th
anniversary edition of god and man at
yale by william f buckley jr this is the
book that started the conservative
movement i'm very honored to have been
asked to write the new introduction to
this edition you can get it on amazon
they're kind of suppressing the results
so just search for it if you look on
amazon just search for god and man at
yale
uh and then go to the newest arrivals
order by newest rivals it should pop up
there and if you order from any other
platform you know type in god and many
yale michael knowles or something like
that you can order it i appreciate
everyone who is who has done that i'm
glad that we're bringing bill buckley
back to being a best seller 70 years
later we'll be right back with a lot
more
this pro-life bill in texas is
anti-woman
it's it's a bunch of men
saying that women
can't kill their children
and so it's anti-woman
except for the
men who can get pregnant
and
uh because they can and uh then the
women who
are who are men
um
aoc can you explain please
none of this is about supporting life
what this is about is controlling
women's bodies and controlling
people who are not cisgender men this is
about making sure that someone like me
as a woman or any menstruating person in
this country cannot make decisions over
their own body and people like governor
abbott and mitch mcconnell want to have
more control over over a woman's body
than that woman or that person has over
themselves hold on wait is it a woman's
body or a menstruating person's body or
it's a woman or a person and it's the
men who first of all in the spirit of
reconciliation and compromise i'm
willing to make a deal right now with
aoc
any menstruating person who wants to get
an abortion i'm fine with that that's
fine if you are a person right now who
is menstruating and you want to get an
abortion
that's fine that's fine by me
that's fine
you know generally speaking people who
are menstruating are not
uh pregnant i don't you know aoc i
thought she would know the fundamentals
of biology here at least the real but
apparently not that even
but i can i'm happy to enlighten people
when you're pregnant you stop
menstruating that's how it goes so
that's fine there we go there's my carve
out okay menstruating people can have
abortions also menstruating person seems
a little sexist to me doesn't it men
stru waiting per sons how about
women
actually better than women's trading how
about
whoa persons how about
son how about
how about whopper daughter serrating
per daughters hmm how about that aoc
i see your woke language and i raise you
a
whopper daughter straight in for
daughters
take that
a very very silly crazy stuff
and anderson cooper has to pretend that
this is serious by the way
now
the
what's funny about it of course is that
you have these two ideas that are in
conflict with one another the idea that
uh
men and women are not different at all
that men can become women women can
become men there's no difference a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
and the idea that women are this special
class of victims and they're oppressed
by men and you've got the oppressor in
the oppressed and you can't change that
and it's just an eternal fact of society
and people notice that these things are
in conflict
you see the same type of conflict in the
debate between homosexuality and
transgenderism homosexuality says that
men are men and women are women and some
some boys like other boys and some girls
like other girls and you're born this
way and there's nothing you can change
about it and transgenderism says
actually there's not even any such thing
as boys and girls boys can be girls and
girls can be boys and men can be women
and so if you were to apply the logic of
transgenderism
to
homosexuality then you would lose the
idea that you're born this way and you
can't change it because not only can you
change your sexual desires but you can
change your sex itself so the solution
then to homosexuality and the question
that used to be asked which is who would
choose this who would choose to be born
this way would be oh well just change it
you're a boy who likes other boys well
now just you know be a boy that likes
girls or or be a girl that likes boys
but just you can just change it because
it's all fluid right
or if you were to apply the logic of
homosexuality to transgenderism you
would lose the entire concept of
transgenderism people are pointing this
out as maybe this will be the moment
that the left comes undone by its own
logic it won't it won't
because
it actually it all kind of goes back to
second wave feminism when second wave
feminism says a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle there's no
difference between men and women the
only difference is some some people have
long hair or something some people wear
skirts
what they're saying is that
man
equals woman they are exactly the same
indiscernible
so if man equals woman that leads
naturally to the homosexual rights
movement and even to gay marriage
because if there's no difference between
men and women then of course men should
marry men and women should marry women
the word marriage would be redefined
just by that very premise and if there's
no difference between men and women then
of course a man can become a woman and a
woman can become a man
because those categories don't mean
anything so unfortunately it actually
does sort of make sense the reason that
that when you listen to aoc she's
getting a little tongue-tied
and she sounds she sounds a little bit
like the taliban doesn't she
and the person and the woman
the reason she's doing that is because
her argument doesn't have logic to it
it's just grunts it's just it's just
interest it's just desire it's not it's
not anything logical
but that's that's our
that's our politics these days
unfortunately some so-called
conservatives are a little a little
confused on sex and gender and abortion
as well notably bruce jenner who is now
running i guess he's still running for
governor of california
and mr jenner goes on cnn and he's asked
about his opinion on abortion
and he
he talks out of both sides of his mouth
i am for a woman's right to choose
i am also for
a state
uh having the ability to make their own
laws
and so i support
texas in that decision that's their
decision
um i'm okay with that
but as far as being a woman's right to
choose i don't see any changes in our
laws in california in the future but
you're fine with the texas law even
though you say
that you support abortion rights you are
fine with the law that essentially
outlaws abortion
i think they have the right in their
state to do what they want to do now do
i agree with the decision or not
no to be honest with you i actually
probably do not agree with the decision
but i agree with they have the right to
make their own decision
now
i actually like this answer i don't
agree with this answer but i like this
answer because what jenner has done here
is flip the usual democrat mealy-mouthed
answer on its head the democrat
mealy-mouthed abortion answer from from
putative fake catholics like mario cuomo
or
or
joe biden
at least in previous years
is listen i personally
do not support abortion
but i would not force my opinion on the
people so i politically i support
abortion but personally i do not support
abortion
and what jenner has done here it's
actually quite clever
is he says
personally i do support abortion but i
would never force my views on the people
of texas i support democracy i support
their right to make their own laws i
love it it's a clever little argument
now
much like the democrats argument
ultimately it doesn't doesn't make a lot
of sense it makes enough sense in that
jenner is a californian and she's
talking sh she see how difficult this is
he's talking about people in texas
but what he's also pointing to here
is federalism is subsidiarity is the
idea that it's not only that the
government the federal government has
rights and it's not only that the people
have rights but the states have rights
too and we forget that a lot
especially as we tear down statues of
robert e lee we'd certainly forget that
a lot
that the states do have they don't have
unlimited rights they don't have the
rights to do anything they want but they
do have some rights and it seems to me
that people of texas have the right to
pass their own laws on abortion and it
seems the same to bruce jenner it seems
the same to me someone who opposes
abortion and to jenner who supports
abortion
that's
that's a big tent that's about as big
ten to party as i can see
some other
putative conservatives mainstream
conservatives
seem to be confused
the view always has
some at least nominal conservative on
the panel the view is that gaggle of
liberal women and they have one woman at
least who's at least sort of kind of
conservative
and so uh megan mccain was filling that
spot for a while negan left the show now
they're bringing in new people so mia
love who was being talked up in recent
years as a major republican figure oh
gosh she could run for president that
sort of thing
she goes on the view and she
offers up what
what i'm sure the view producers
consider to be the arch conservative
position
on abortion and life
and the sexual revolution
namely
just pump women full of birth control
i think it's false choices
they're giving women false choices this
is what frustrates me about government
instead of actually taking care of the
story from the beginning they're trying
to pick up broken pieces and they're
making it worse why not try and empower
women why not giving them more options
when it comes to their reproductive
health like providing over-the-counter
contraceptives birth control pills
instead of condoms and plan b i mean i
am pro-life
i've always been pro-life with the
exception of rape incest and the life of
a mother i don't think government should
be going into families when it comes to
making a decision about about such
important issues and personal issues
that are damaging
to women so here's what i think why not
treat women like
assets that can be developed instead of
liabilities that need to be managed
not sure i understood all of that word
salad but i think she's right in the
first part which is this is about false
choices
i think this is exactly about false
choices i think the view is giving its
audience
false choices here between
liberals
and
people who sort of pretend to be
conservative
i don't think the conservative view
on abortion is that we need to pump
women full of contraception and only
kill one percent of babies
i don't
i think the conservative view on
abortion is
and you know forgive my radicalism here
that we shouldn't kill any of the babies
and we should encourage life and the
openness to life and stable
relationships and marriage
and and monogamy and
and
a stable society with the stable
fundamental political element of the
society which is the family
i think i think that would be the
conservative argument
not
what we're getting from the view but
this it just reminds me
any time i tune into a show like the
view it reminds me
that so much of our politics
is just fake it's just a show
it's just pretend
it is
a liberal regime with a few court
jesters
the court jester conservatives whose job
it is to provide the appearance of
opposition
when in fact what what they do is they
serve to legitimize the liberal regime
phyllis schlafly a great american
conservative woman
famously called in the 20th century for
a choice not an echo
i'm pro-choice in that regard i want
there to be a choice between liberals
and conservatives not just between
liberals and slightly less liberals
okay i want
an actual choice here
and
when the view presents this argument as
as an the wide choice between a liberal
and a conservative when actually they
have the same premises the same basic
ideas about life about
about the sexual revolution about the
family about individual autonomy they
agree on everything basically they just
agree
they just disagree on how many babies
should be killed and they disagree on
how
much we should promote
contraceptives
no one is suggesting we promote life
really
just some saying well maybe we should
kill fewer people
that's not a choice that's
there there was a an interesting
character curtis yarvin went on tucker
carlson's show on his fox nation show
yesterday and curtis jordan is
a
more radical right-wing thinker i've
i've read a bit of his stuff
and he he makes this same point actually
that so much of our politics is just
kind of fake
we think that the real battle of our
government is between
trump and biden
when in fact the president himself
has relatively very little power even
compared to presidents a hundred years
ago
that the actual political fights are
sort of hidden and they don't really
change
that actually
actually the fight the political battles
that we're seeing on the view that's not
that's not really what's going on
because they're all within the dominant
regime
speaking of squishy conservatives
president trump is set to endorse the
opponent of liz cheney
in the next congressional election
no surprise here there's no love lost
between trump and cheney
and
so he's and i think he's going to
endorse harriet hageman who's a wyoming
attorney
she's going to primary cheney
it brings me to a point that people
brought up i mentioned it too when when
cheney was being ousted from from
leadership
people pointed out that
liz cheney
actually has a relatively conservative
voting record in congress
not perfect but she was relatively
concerned we would we would generally
agree with her voting record in congress
more so
even than the woman who replaced her in
republican leadership
which is a little bit of a problem
but
on this decision to primary liz cheney
or to support the primary challenger
what we're really talking about here is
not your opinion on tax cuts not even
your opinion on abortion you know or
your opinion on immigration
it's about
whether you're a real conservative in
practice in effect
are you at the crucial moments
going to stand up
for half the country for the for
traditional americans
or
at the crucial moments
are you going to cave
and are you going to defend nancy pelosi
and are you going to be her prop and
clown for for instance the january 6th
commission
the problem with liz cheney like romney
and others is at the crucial moment they
cave they're good 90 of the time but at
the crucial moment well the crucial
moment is when we need you
speaking of republicans who sometimes go
a little squishy
there's some good news out of the gop up
in south dakota republican governor
christie gnome
has just signed an excellent executive
order on abortion now christie gnome
hit the national circuit during the
coronavirus lockdowns because she
wouldn't lock down her state so everyone
really liked her and she's an attractive
woman and she's articulate and so people
started talking about her as a potential
presidential candidate i i know now
you're not allowed to mention that
christine is attractive matt walsh did
that and she like yelled at him for it
and called him a sexist but it's true
she is attractive and that's one of the
reasons people talked her up
then she started to go a little squishy
there was a transgender bill that went
before her desk
it was a simple bill that said don't let
men compete in women's sports
seems simple to me
and she wouldn't sign it she wouldn't
sign it presumably because her corporate
donors called and threatened her and she
caved i i don't know that for a fact but
that seems to be what happened similar
thing happened to asa hutchinson down in
arkansas republican governor there okay
so that's too bad that really makes me
doubt that she could be a strong
national leader then
when she when she went after walsh in
this very lib way of saying you're a
sexist look my eyes are up here you know
i just thought okay that's pathetic you
know let's give me a break so now i
think gnome realizes
that she's losing her conservative
support the whole thing that
brought her up to become a national
figure she's lost that because she's
presumably caving to in special
interests in in south dakota so now
she's going right-wing again she just
signed an executive order
banning telemedicine abortions in south
dakota the order directs the south
dakota department of health quote to
establish rules preventing telemedicine
abortions in south dakota it restricts
chemical abortions in the state it
says that abortion drugs can only be
prescribed or dispensed by a physician
after an in-person examination from a
physician licensed in south dakota
it blocks
receiving abortion drugs in the mail it
prevents abortion drugs from being
dispensed in schools around state
grounds and it reiterates
that uh licensed physicians must ensure
informed consent laws
uh okay this is good stuff i like it i
know you know sometimes conservatives
they they spend more time attacking each
other than they do attacking the left
and i get it especially when
conservatives are out of power there's
some jockeying there's a question of
what is the vision here that has to be
done but something we really admire
about the left or that we're impressed
by at least is that the left knows how
to circle the wagons the left knows how
to come together at the crucial moment
and do things and the right doesn't do
that as well
so to this i say
good job christina this is good i like
it good stuff other governors should
follow suit glad to see it if christinom
went a little squish for a while the
pressure was tough you know okay that's
too bad let's let's move on let's get
better and don't do that again and maybe
let's just be more conservative
she sees what side the bread is buttered
on okay and uh and let's keep more of
this i love it other governors should
copy what what governor gnome did here
now speaking of murder
in in various states in the northern
part of america
kamala harris you'll recall during the
george floyd riots
not only encouraged people to riot in
the streets not only
gave spiritual and political support to
these rioters and arsonists and looters
and killers but she gave financial
support as well she posted around the
minnesota freedom fund which is a fund
to bail out violent people who were
arrested for rioting and she posted this
around joe biden's staff members did the
same thing
okay
the minnesota freedom fund
uh just posted bail posts bail for a lot
of criminals not just the ones
associated with the george floyd riots
including 47 year old george howard who
is being held on domestic assault
charges okay
so kama lahara says support this
jailbreak fund the jail break fund bails
out this wife beater george howard
now according to minneapolis police
george howard has just shot and killed
38 year old luis damien martinez ortiz
during a road rage incident in
minneapolis
surveillance video shows ortiz and
howard getting into an altercation on an
on-ramp
and then this guy that kamala harris
bailed out just killed this other guy 38
years old had his whole life in front of
him
uh
she's not gonna get any pushback for it
and and no mainstream outlets i suspect
are going to report on it
or very very few but you'll hear it here
someone is dead today
because of these jailbreak
movements
jailbreak movements that are not only
supported in general by democrat
politicians some republican politicians
too i'm sorry to say
but that are report that are supported
specifically by them this is this is how
democrats stop crime
they break out wife beaters so that the
wife beaters can go shoot people on the
street
in san francisco right now they've got
they've got a new method to try to
reduce crime because crime is through
the roof in san francisco you thought it
was bad that some californian threw an
egg at larry elder stuff is really bad
in san francisco so the new attempt to
reduce crime
is not
my now look i'm not an expert on
criminology but my suggestion would be
arrest the criminals and keep them in
jail for a long time and for the ones
who commit capital offenses kill them
that's my suggestion okay maybe i'm but
maybe i'm a little thick i'm a little
stupid i don't
i'm not such a genius that i could
pursue what they're doing in san
francisco which is
to pay
the criminals
san francisco they're going to pay
criminals
300 a month
not to shoot people if you don't
if you don't shoot people in san
francisco you can make 300 a month
i
i promise
not to shoot anyone in san francisco
not just now but ever okay i promised
where is my check
am i going to get my check
i don't think this is going to work
one i don't think it's going to work for
me to get the jack in two i don't think
this is going to work to reduce crime
i think that the left is getting this
just totally
totally backwards here
and i think that
crime is going to shoot through the roof
and we're now subsidizing criminals
apparently i think statues are going to
be torn down i think our elections are
not going to be
considered fair neither side has faith
in the elections right now
we talk about the mean old taliban over
there in afghanistan
that worries me it worries me more to
see these kinds of things
going on here the the sheer
control the capriciousness the whims of
the regime
and we what what do we have to fight
back against it
i think we still have a little bit of
time but not so much it's running out
i'm michael knows this michael nola
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borah our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show virginia creates a time
capsule so future generations can learn
why america collapsed and as americans
remain trapped in afghanistan coveted
lockdown's loom and culture war breaks
out everywhere the biden administration
has a new old plan throw money at all
the things that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen